[Musica]
Un'immagine vale più di mille parole
E fin qui nulla di nuovo È una frase che
conosciamo tutti quanti
però poi voglio farvi subito una domanda
sapete Quante fotografie vengono
scattate ogni anno nel mondo
Immagino di no io l'ho scoperto un po'
per caso di recente quando mi è capitato
di leggere un articolo in cui si
riportavano tutte le Stime sul numero di
fotografie scattate ogni anno ogni mese
Ogni giorno Insomma statistiche
sull'utilizzo della fotografia oggi
bene Non che mi aspettassi dei numeri
bassi Però devo dire che sono rimasto
Comunque
impressionato e quando ho letto
1,72 trilioni di fotografia
sono rimasto impressionato perché
un numero del genere è proprio non
riesco a quantificarlo cioè quasi non mi
dice nulla vi confesso che son dovuto
andare a ricercare in rete per scoprire
che un trilione equivale a mille
miliardi nella scala anglosassone mille
miliardi troppi Zeri c'è proprio non
sono dei numeri che non riesco proprio a
capire Allora Per aiutarvi vi dico che
da quando ho iniziato a parlare sarà
passato un minuto poco più bene nel
frattempo nel mondo sono state scattate
più di 3 milioni e mezzo di fotografie
A questo punto mi è venuto in mente il
ho pensato al famoso aforisma e poi mi è
venuta spontanea chiedermi Ma quindi è
ancora vero che
un'immagine una fotografia a tutto
questo valore
Io vi confesso in economia sono proprio
una capra non ci capisco nulla però una
cosa basilare l'ho capita e più aumenta
l'offerta di un bene più il suo valore
diminuisce
cioè stiamo facendo della fotografia
l'ennesimo prodotto usa e Get e Stiamo
togliendo quel valore che invece deve
avere una fotografia
che poi a pensarci bene sta storia che è
Un'immagine vale più di mille parole
esattamente il motivo perché ho deciso
di fare il fotografo io con le parole ho
sempre fatto un po' fatica
da piccolo balbettavo era un bambino
super emotivo
pronunciare mille parole in pubblico
è impossibile sarebbe stato
semplicemente impossibile
per cui come
per tante persone anche per me la
fotografia è stata quasi una terapia e
forse semplicemente
l'alternativa più immediata al mio
bisogno di comunicare il linguaggio
adatto a me per connettermi con gli
altri
insomma questo è il valore che ha una
fotografia per me misurata in parole
vale più di mille tantissimo le parole
sono importanti hanno un valore hanno un
peso questo io lo so bene
per cui niente vi ho detto Insomma avete
capito che sono una persona di poche
parole però quello che voglio dirvi
stasera è che proprio perché un'immagine
quindi una fotografia vale più di mille
parole bene Allora io voglio essere
anche un fotografo di poche fotografie
la mia esperienza mi dice che mi
conviene e ora ve la spiego insomma la
racconto velocemente mostrandovi una
fotografia una sola per essere coerente
Eccola qua
bene questa fotografia per me ha un
valore immenso e
diciamole proprio grazie a questa
fotografia se sono stato invitato su
questo palco
e rappresenta delle donne iraniane che
urlano slogan di protesta contro il
regime dal tetto della propria
abitazione L'ho scattata a Teheran nel
E fa parte di una piccola serie di
fotografie con cui ho raccontato questa
protesta dei tetti
una decina di giorni prima si erano
svolte delle elezioni presidenziali
importantissime per il paese e le
elezioni che poi si rivelarono una farsa
per cui la gente iniziò a scendere
immediatamente dopo in piazza
manifestazione oceaniche forse le più
importanti dai tempi della rivoluzione
islamica dal 79
e la sera quando le piazze Si svuotavano
si riempivano i tetti e aveva luogo
questa quest'altra protesta molto più
simbolica
bene io fu l'unico fotografo a
raccontare la storia di questa protesta
ora vi dico come è successa questa cosa
però fotografare in una dittatura come
potete immaginare e non è una cosa
semplice per me era diventato ancora più
complicato perché qualche giorno dopo il
mio arrivo a Teheran era stato fermato
dalla polizia e mi avevano trattenuto
per tre giorni ma era andata bene alla
fine dopo tre giorni di interrogatori mi
avevano restituito l'attrezzatura e il
passaporto e mi avevano lasciato andare
la raccomandazione
di Non fotografare più nulla che potesse
avere il minimo riferimento alla
politica ora la raccomandazione di un
poliziotto iraniano fidatevi mette una
certa soggezione e adesso curano anche
gli amici iraniani a dirmi di quanto ero
stato fortunato e che però adesso basta
foto sarebbe stato troppo pericoloso
farsi beccare una seconda volta per me
ma forse e soprattutto per loro che mi
ha accompagnavano che mi stavano
aiutando
Ovviamente io non potevo non volevo
tradire la fiducia delle persone che mi
stavano aiutando
per cui seguirono dei giorni di grande
frustrazione
lì fuori si stava facendo la storia era
un momento importantissimo per il paese
e io ero costretto in un appartamento
senza la possibilità di fotografare fare
il mio lavoro ero nervosissimo
però alla fine fu proprio questa
limitazione a rivelarsi la mia più
grande fortuna
fu il non potere e fece sì che io
attivassi tutti i sensi e grazie a
questo che scoprì la la protesta dei
tetti e negative soprattutto il profondo
significato simbolico che rappresentava
Se io avessi avuto la possibilità di
scattare in libertà probabilmente avrei
seguito la notizia più fotogenica e
quella che la più immediata quella che
si aspettano i giornali quella che del
resto stavano fotografando Giustamente
tutti i miei colleghi
e soprattutto i manifestanti Cioè se io
avessi avuto la possibilità di scattare
in libertà magari avrei scattato
migliaia di fotografie che sommate tutte
insieme non avrebbero avuto il valore di
questa qui
invece tornai a casa con una manciata di
fotografia 50 fotografie non so un poco
più di un rullino di una volta
Però per la prima volta avevo come la
strana sensazione di essere soddisfatto
Hai ragione infatti da lì a poco
queste fotografie questa in particolare
fece leggero del mondo con ho pubblicato
ovunque e hanno vinto dei riconoscimenti
prestigiosissimi e ancora oggi a
distanza di quasi 15 anni sono qui a
raccontare la storia di queste
fotografie
ora Forse ho fatto un esempio un po'
estremo e parlato di dittatura parlato
di fotografare in un luogo in cui non
hai la libertà di esprimerti di
raccontare quello che vuoi
però oggi che di esperienza un po' ne ho
fatta io vi posso assicurare posso dire
con certezza che i lavori migliori le
fotografie migliori le ho fatte quando
ho scattato poco
quando mi sono lasciato il tempo
per di connettermi con il mio soggetto
prima di avere l'ansia di fotografarlo
quando selezionato bene
cosa e come fotografarlo anche quando
ero libero di di scattare mille
fotografie
la fotografia è un linguaggio
potentissimo che però come ogni
strumento dotato di un potenziale così
alto usato senza cognizione di causa non
rende solamente sterile può generare
l'effetto contrario a quello che era il
nostro scopo
bene oggi
in questo strumento a disposizione di
tutti Basta infilarci una mano in tasca
e siamo pronti a scattare una fotografia
ormai lo facciamo in maniera quasi
istintiva e questa è una cosa bella
intendiamo cioè Viva la democrazia Viva
il fatto che siamo tutti abbiamo tutti
la possibilità di scattare una
fotografia
per oggi quasi non ci rendiamo più conto
del motivo per cui stiamo facendo quella
fotografia ci ritroviamo il telefono in
mano e scattiamo senza poi avere uno
scopo preciso
alla recita di mia figlia la prima
recita di mia figlia che va in prima
elementare mi sono girato un attimo
verso la platea e mi sono reso conto che
non c'era un solo genitore che non
avesse in mano il proprio smartphone
bambini erano lì a cercare quello
sguardo i propri genitori come per
Cercare conforto come per dire Guarda
mamma Guarda papà lo sto facendo per voi
Insomma cercavano di connettersi con noi
ma mi sono reso conto che facevano
fatica a distinguere a riconoscere i
volti dei propri genitori nascosti
dietro un muro di telefonini
sto dicendo niente di nuovo
Me ne rendo conto eh Però io voglio
convincervi che guardare costantemente
il mondo attraverso lo schermo del
vostro telefonino Magari pubblicare
tutto in tempo reale non ci rende più
connessi agli altri il contrario
Il nostro scopo sarebbe quello di
lasciare una traccia però lasciamo così
tante tracce che nessuno riuscirà più ad
orientarsi vogliamo costruire
una memoria però Costruiamo Alla fine
degli archivi di ricordi così vasti che
ci saremo i primi a perderci così dentro
io concludo voglio concludere
lasciandovi un compitino un consiglio
diciamo voglio lasciarvi un consiglio
Prendetevi il tempo per guardare le
vostre fotografie ci vorrà un po' perché
saranno migliaia però un po' per fare un
po' per volta fatelo
e leggetele e le selezionate le leggete
quelle che per voi hanno davvero un
valore importante quelle che vi
ricordano qualcosa che non volete
dimenticare o quelle che pensare che
possono essere importanti anche per gli
altri del resto Fateci quello che volete
Io dico buttatele se non avete il
coraggio mettetele da parte lontano da
voi vedrete che a un certo punto
svaniranno da sole
volete fare un condividere un ricordo di
una bella giornata passata con gli amici
evitate di inviare 10 20 fotografie
attraverso i social volete fare un
grande regalo selezionate le selezionate
una stampatela e regalate quella avete
fatto il regalo più bello
Insomma
restituiamo alla fotografia il valore di
mille parole
Grazie
[Musica]